marie laforêt oui
toujours toujours ma musique
désormais
c'est jean qui le jour magnifique pour
nous c'est claude lelouch et bien je ne
demande qu'à vous avez jamais fait de
film ensemble dans sérieux non il n'a
pas voulu
non ya pas voulu il avait non pas celle
là je vais prendre truc à la place oui
et au point où il en est
non tout c'est vrai il s'est également
engagée marie doit écouter non j'avais
vu la fille aux yeux bleus les yeux d'or
d'honneur la fille aux yeux
et albicocco a dégainé avant moi hein
voilà les pauses et les îles épuisé ah
bah ouais moi c'est d'abord ça
fait main peut-être mais d'abord bague
au doigt marie laforêt bonsoir bonsoir
toi
parce que marina foïs et pas seulement
la poule aux oeufs d'or c'est pas
seulement 50 films c'est pas seulement
les livres le théâtre c'était aussi 35
millions d'albums vendus
encore mieux c'est qu'est alors et à
tuer des maisons de disques oui vous
n'avez pas de balance g et sur les 35
millions vous avez de très peu près
parce que toutes ces compila qui sortent
en ce moment qu'on voit là le jour sur
la fnac il y avait cette compil à lui
saute comté de marie-mai de ils ont fait
cette compilation 2010 en deux en quoi
un cd monde est bon
non voici c'est ce que c'est pas vrai si
reçu 9000 euros amitié à lederman sa vie
je n'ai pas parlé d hermann [ __ ]
alors je te dire ce que je pense
d'ailleurs
tous ces succès voulait pas chanter sur
scène depuis trente ans plus 1972
exactement depuis trente trois ans 33
ans l'âge du christ tu te rends compte
l'âge du christ que j'ai pas chanter et
vous allez leur chanter sur scène du 12
au 17 septembre théâtre des bouffes
parisiens ouais depuis un mois que je
suis évidemment obligé de faire votre
top 6 des chansons je suis
enthousiasmé je suis enchanté je suis
ravi c'est ravissant ces charmants
seguer ce tonique je suis enchanté de
faire ça enfin bien payé non
ce que tu sais pas c'est que derrière
cette opération il ya une logistique
impressionnante un requin du show biz
qui est en train de devenir le parrain
parisienne un tycoon un violent ouais je
dois dire que de ce côté là il faut
quand même je crois que gérard louvin à
côté c'est un petit
rappeler que didier violent également il
a confirmé tout à l'heure dans les loges
didier tu es chaud mais c'est pas moi
qui produit quelque chose cela cessera
pas que j'ai baisé la main
c'est à baiser la mer je suis vengé
d'avant
j'ai trois gardes
comme quoi ta maman vient regarde bien
il ya un producteur absolument mais
c'est un requin petits plats africains
quand on se méfie pas parce que au début
sympa oui il a l'air comme ça pato la
grippe mi novembre je dirais pas donné
tu vas m
[Musique]
le mât cotée qui gère humain est un
petit garçon le nouveau requins du show
biz le producteur de marie laforêt c'est
laurent ruquier
voilà pour ce port en tout cas pour ce
spectacle mais c'est toi qui va produire
marie laforêt oui exactement c'est toi
qui paye parce que j'avais envie de la
voir chanter est ce que tu peux avoir
assez et
c'est appris comment cet amour de marie
laforêt de
fait attention à ce que je dis depuis
toujours voilà c'est très bien ça depuis
toujours par les clans je peux rien moi
je ne connaissais que les grands succès
ce que vous avez passé tout à l'heure et
et que tout le public connaît mais après
grâce aux fameuses compile même si elle
n'a rien touché dessus c'est compile
auront eu au moins un mérite c'est que
j'ai découvert des tas de chansons que
j'ignorais et qui sont toutes plus
belles les unes que les autres ce qui
est plus de 300 chansons
sur scène il faut dire que marie va
chanter ses grands succès ça fait
plaisir la majorité du public mais elle
va aussi chanter les chansons que on va
dire ses femmes ses aficionados ceux qui
connaissent tout son père répertoire les
chansons sud américaine les chansons
moins connues mais qui sont toutes aussi
belles et plus belle même parfois que
les grands succès koné sur la carte
noire parker non non c'est en train de
le ré apprendre sans toi et que tu
gagnes les chansons qu'elle a chanté
maman tu crois à ça j'ai certainement
oui on va voir on va faire une interview
au matin je suis pas chanter
[Musique]
vous vous rendez vous me répondez
chanter quand vous avez chanté la
chanson est pas chanter quand voulait
pas chanter on va voir à marée haute à
marée basse oui non quan on chantait
c'était quoi à marée haute non je te
réponds tu chantes et non sur le champ
ou pas chanter je reconnais chantera pas
si cette annonce était alors on y va à
marée haute à marée basse wissant t aime
moi jusqu'à demain
sachant chanter montagne et champêtre
santé chanter à chanter est moins 30
secondes de plus ça changera ah non non
non c'est
aussi un test pour voir si tu as tout
cas tête alzheimer
et toi qui sais oui chanter encore
barbecues
n'ont pas chanté n'a pas chanté barbecue
bah oui en anglais à la fin j'ai chanté
une
broche
la vague arrive elle arrive à gary
baseball magazine ouais santé c'est
julien c'est julie julie fléchir c'est
jean-michel n'en sait pas chanter ça
jamais l'être c'est pas grand mais c'est
sympa
c'est oui je les sentais dans une tôt
que d amor bras
estimé
elles sont bien faites à l'époque c'est
pas grand mais je regrettais en plus
c'est tout moi donc ça pas de gentils
choukaj ou genou époux épouse sûrement
c'est moi mais où est donc ornicar non
paulo elle pense est clair qu'ils
étaient moins la prime guitare
chanter
gilet en laine
non bon alors j'espère que c'est moi qui
fais les questions car on sait
maintenant contre
liverpool oh oui roubles et mulhouse
mais on en plus le générique du para oui
mulhouse blues bien pris non
saint-tropez blues sa tante et siffle
aussi fait ma fille oui c'est suce ma
fille
très jolie très jolies tenues dauphin le
cachalot tous les dauphins chanteuse
santé chanter cerf-volant santé bien sûr
oui oui
oui oui brachial ont tué des en plus tu
pues
très marrante le nord est restée très
bien qu'on vient rien mais ce que j en
viens viens viens viens vers chante
aussi bien sur la montagne chantait
malheureusement rit oui je viens oui je
viens non non non non warawa
warszawa oui 13,6 voir sa voix et mourir
oui non non
c'est moi d'amour comme à une autre
oui bien
minutes on répertoire chanté d'abord
suis moi l'amour comme à 16 ans et je ne
connaissais pas fais moi l'amour comme à
une autre que j'ai entendu pour la
première fois il ya quinze ans j'ai bien
alors je suis folle de vous eh oui si
folle que vous chantez santé je suis
folle tout ouïe santé sûrement non non
je vois pas où il est mais lundi où tu
l'as fait chanter jolie guitare nantais
chanter si même si tu la chanteuse amy
lee tard c'est mon cher l'accordéon
je sentais ni sony ni guitare bien
johnny guitare de l'aj auxerre serait en
août
tu t'y connais à mort c'est incroyable
on a une ou deux que je connaisse un
manque la tour de babel waouh issaoui
alors le chien de bébé
au feu de bois ça c'est un piège là on
fait de bois c'est pas chanter non c'est
l'amour au feu de bois oui c'est vrai
marina fromage quatre saisons
lève-toi et chante avec moi oui oui
c'est santé lève toi et marche non il
n'est pas chanter c'est bien il a neigé
sur yesterday ouais il a pissé sur
images je regrette de l'avoir fait mais
ça va venir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu